one of the most important preconditions
of a good relationship is a satisfactory
perspective on being single the more we
are happy to be on our own the more we
will be able to exercise the correct
degree of caution around finding a new
companion the Bedrock of true love is
Happy singledum unfortunately our
societies do very little to help us be
calm or at ease in our own company
singldum is framed as an involuntary
depressing and always hopefully
temporary State the notion that someone
might want or need to be on their own
perhaps for a long while terrifies a
world shaped by Legions of silently
miserable couples who need confirmation
that they have not chosen the wrong path
to enforce the idea of what single
people are missing advertisers can never
have enough of showing off tantalizing
images of Happy couples walking hand in
hand on on beaches and most
entertainment venues holiday
destinations and social occasions feel
compelled to patronize overcharge and
otherwise demean anyone who has the
impedance to venture out on their own
unfortunately being miserable while
single fatally undermines our judgment
about who we might get together with
when someone is starving they will eat
anything
Dostoyevsky wrote a harrowing short
story about a famished child who eats a
candle made of pig fat and we're equally
liable in emotional desperation to run
into the nearest nightclub to secure a
chump will be appalled to find beside us
at Daybreak we eventually learn being in
an unsatisfactory relationship is
clearly worse that is even more lonely
than being alone
the central challenge of being alone is
coping with the fear of what singlehood
means being alone is bearable in
relation to how normal that highly
nebulous yet highly influential concept
the condition feels to us at any given
point it can either be a break from an
honorably busy life or sure evidence
that we are an unwanted wretched
disgusting and emotionally diseased
being
this is tricky But ultimately very
hopeful for it suggests that if only we
could work on what being alone means to
us we could theoretically endure long
periods alone
to build ourselves a new mental model of
what being alone should truly mean we
might rehearse a few of the following
arguments despite what an unfriendly
voice inside our heads might tell us we
are the ones who can choose whether or
not to be alone
our Solitude is willed rather than
imposed no one ever needs to be alone so
long as they don't mind who they are
with
but we do mind the wrong kind of company
is a great deal lonelier for us than
being by ourselves that is it's further
from what matters to us more grating in
its insincerity and more of a reminder
of disconnection and misunderstanding
than is the conversation we can have in
the quiet of our own minds being alone
is not proof that we have been rejected
by the world it's a sign that we've
taken a good look at the available
options and have with wisdom done some
rejecting ourselves
another big thought is that we need to
appreciate how long it will take to find
someone given how choosy we are for very
good reasons we aren't just looking for
anyone the right candidate will be no
less easy to find than a great job or a
beautiful house it might take many
months probably years expectations
matter if we regard a decade as a
plausible time frame then six months
we'll Skip by there is no better
guarantee of a successful relationship
than knowing that we could and can
manage perfectly well on our own it
means that we will only look for someone
who can deeply contribute to our life
not someone who can do the laundry with
us or keep us company on Sunday evenings
this gives us the strength to back out
of unsatisfactory unions as quickly as
we should being in a couple can't and
shouldn't mean that we are utterly
reliant on the other for our self-esteem
our daily self-management or for the
meeting of our domestic needs when we
have under our belt a significant
experience of thriving on our own we
will be able to cope with the inevitable
points at which even a very nice partner
can't sustain us we'll be less demanding
more competent and more forensic in what
we seek from a lover it turns out that
our willingness to stay on our own is
what centrally predicts How likely we'll
be to find and bring to fruition a
relationship with someone else being at
ease with being single is the needed
secure platform from which to make a
sane and wise choice about who to create
a joint life with